well it's an ad designed to help educate
people about monkey pox and it's gaining
attention but for the wrong reasons some
say the Southern Nevada Health District
is spreading stigma rather than
awareness
it kind of reduces the community down to
a sex cells ad Campaign which is
productive and you know there's much
more to our community Brady McGill is
not thrilled with the latest
advertisement about the monkey pox
vaccine he says this online ad showing
that semi-naked man sends the wrong
message other ads that have come out
from snht have a little bit more
information are geared to more audiences
that are wide reaching so I think that
ads that do that and get people out and
doing the right thing and practicing
safer activity out in the world is the
way to go the ad is from the Southern
Nevada Health District as it promotes
awareness as monkey pox cases rise in
Clark County latest reports show 166
cases with 98 percent of those involving
men and 71 percent among the lgbtq plus
Community an ad like that is really
meant to be kind of attention grabbing
but at the same time it can kind of
harken some stigma and some
stigmatization that happens in our
community leaders at the southern Nevada
Health District tells us the online ad
ran for a limited time and has since
been moved according to the CDC
monkeypox can spread by close or
intimate contact and even touching
Fabrics like bedding or towels the
illness typically lasts two to four
weeks and as Las Vegas Pride prepares to
celebrate Pride next month organizers
say awareness is crucial to that Pride
we're going to have a health and
wellness section in the festival we'll
be able to have vaccinations on site so
if you're looking for a covid-19
vaccinations or monkey pox vaccinations
you can get this at the festival on
October 8th
well if you're interested in getting the
two dose monkey pox vaccine we have a
link to schedule your appointment on
8newsnow.com